i just got stood up
on a hinge date
well he cancelled like an hour before
the date
um and that's fine
then you didn't get stood up you
cancelled an hour before that's not yet
that's not the definition of no stop
that's not what happens when you show up
the dude says i'm going to be there and
he never shows up if you get canceled on
an hour before that's not being stood up
sometimes he flaked things come up keep
maybelline
flake maybe got cold feet i would wish
but the [ __ ] who stood me up at least
would have given me a one-hour courtesy
because there ain't nothing [ __ ]
worse than showing up to a [ __ ]
expecting something to go well and just
being left in the dark you sitting there
for 40 50 one hour
is this [ __ ] ever showing up so
you didn't get stood up but i just want
to start though let's keep watching yeah
you know what i'd rather i'd rather not
go anyway
so i'm exotic
and i'm that's cat that's cat listen
man canceled on you you butt hurt about
it you don't have to come up after the
thing but kind of
it's like the dudes who were like hey
what up mom i'm not interested well you
walking again anyway [ __ ] like it's the
same thing that's not what it is what is
it
what is it i just got stood up he can't
sell an hour before so i don't care i
don't i'd rather not go anyways anyways
i'm not starting eating my emotions
yes out of all the places where you went
to no i'll be there you want that
dopamine right from the face fine it's
fine i get it yay
boo boo honey chicken cherry chop honey
bun a bunch i get it but no the i don't
care part yeah i don't care so i'm gonna
go to sonic after and put do a whole ass
video on it no
no say you do
no you give a shita
i uk
you give a [ __ ]
they're never gonna know this song it
doesn't matter all my haitians know it's
a remix all right i got my blast
everything is okay now
but here's my question
maybe somebody can answer this
why do men ask you out
pick the time in the place and then
cancel
like why ask me in the first place if
you didn't want to go
because sometimes things that happen
ain't about you
it ain't
a cancellation ain't about you
you're actually it's [ __ ] up i'm about
to say you're actually not that
important
that it's gonna be about you
specifically
it's not you
it's not because something's happened to
you
hmm
weird formulation of words you know my
my my my
the way i speak and everything and stuff
it's not because something happened
to you
that it happens at you that is directed
to you
you understand someone canceling on you
you don't take that personal because oh
my god
why did he do that man always no people
cancel it happens they cancel
that's it
now what you have to do is if they
always cancel on you then the common
denominator then is you then it's
absolutely you yeah
it's a one-time thing uh
what yeah all right i'll i'll give you
i'll give you the multiple reasons
reason one sometimes something just
happens when it comes up
that happens sometimes all right so
sometimes you need to cancel
reason two that someone might ask you
out and then end up canceling they get
cold feet
maybe they're not over an x maybe they
got emotional stuff going on maybe they
[ __ ] up in their head it happens
people lack confidence sometimes they
want a date but then they realize like
yo i'm not really still not about you go
ahead then option three which is like
generally most of the time right because
what you know you're a young woman you
probably saw a guy you thought he was
really cute guess what uh while he might
have been the guy you were really
interested you were one of the many
women he was interested in okay when it
comes to online dating
there are certain men who get most of
the dates right they get most of the
options and so people gravitate towards
these profiles because these guys are
very endearing it's kind of tough to
realize that the guy that you're really
interested in is only partially
interested in you and when you're an
option amongst many
well you get treated as disposable
because you literally are
and so once people sit there like why
why would a guy ask me out and then not
for one of the many reasons i just named
it happens all the time and it's still
not about you that's right even if
you're not if you even if you're when
you're an option it is it is
basically you not that important
it is about you you not that girl let's
just because let me tell you something
there's a level to who gets passed on
right yeah generally here's what it
comes down to the difference between
your standards and what you can command
out there meaning right if you're a 10
out of 10 woman okay hypothetical and
the dude's like just a regular joe blow
he's not canceling on you he'll cancel
his family before he cancels on you you
don't want to say he'll cancel his job
he'll cancel his bank account [ __ ] what
you want
i'll pay for anything yeah sam you get
what i'm trying to say yeah to some
degree it is about the legs they
understand that right they feel
undesired in a lot of these
circumstances just like yo what the [ __ ]
is going on so it really comes down to
what can you command and what are you
asking for like what do you have to
offer what can you command right because
if
and there's nothing wrong i'm not
telling people to change their stances
i'm not trying to say
i just know that if i go after a super
hot woman who's got a popping instagram
or whatever she's gonna handsome on your
ass cause she got other dudes in the dm
i'll fly you to ibiza
kabifa ibiza man
off while you wait
so you dispose of them so folks is that
is that what or what uh online dating
does right now
make people more disposable online
dating is just a tool
that
lets you market yourself to more people
right
back in the day if you have something to
market if you were really attractive and
you were popular you didn't people were
disposable yeah it just amplifies what
already exists you get what i'm trying
to say i see you popular people back in
the day had all these women going after
themselves they ignored people it is
what it is there was a role such as the
popular guy or the popular yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and they would smash a
girl and just not talk to her ever again
yeah same idea same thing they could
same same i see same same so when people
sit there and like i don't get why
somebody it's like i think deep down you
know deep down you know the answer
it's just too much of an ego blow to
like have to admit it
and so that's why i always tell people
to not when they go into dating not to
take everything so personal not to get
so overly invested that your self-esteem
gets shattered every time you know
someone got mad at me one time because i
said that
but it's like as a guy if you're just
starting the date and you're trying to
figure it out the worst thing you could
do is just zone in on one girl and put
all your focus on that the reason being
is if things go south which vast
majority of the time they do as a young
average man
you're going to be devastated whereas
you know if you keep your eggs in a few
different baskets and the people who
reciprocate interest and really show you
reciprocate back and there's a mutual
that's much better
um generally people get really butt-hurt
over the fact that a date didn't work
out because they put so many eggs in
that basket yep
i don't know how many dates this girl's
been on i don't know how much they've
invested each other so i can't really
say it her specifically but yeah i said
dude it's like man i was so excited what
was it the first one it's like
calm down it's one date chill you guys
haven't even met each other you don't
even know you're judging by how butt
hurt you are over this i can tell you
were way more invested in this than
probably she was absolutely which is
always an issue because like
most people take it as a red flag
if you are so invested in someone you've
not even met yeah no man how do you like
me this month it's like you can't say
how do you want it you can't you can't
say on the first date i love you
that'd be weird oh you can and people do
i know i know i know but that's a red
flag it's exactly what you're saying are
you agree it's a red flag because how
it's like [ __ ] you don't know how so it
makes people suspicious of you i just
want to say it's just like talking about
kids on the first date
i mean you can i've definitely talked
about kids on the floor i wouldn't yeah
you could talk about policies you want
kids
it's how you say do you want kids with
me it's see that's different
that's different i don't there's
anything wrong about ask like what do
you think about marriage that's
something you're interested in versus
like like so when you get married or
putting the pressure on this people feel
the difference yeah yeah so i think you
can't talk about these things this is
how you bro absolutely but always uh you
know some people say the difference
between saying yeah i mentioned falling
in love and i love you
whoa
whoa
most girls if you sat down with him he
said i'm interested in falling in love
again they'd be like that's awesome
that's awesome
i love you
he's gonna cut me up and turn me into a
lampshade you know what i'm saying like
we don't know so anyways let us know
what you guys think